bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant l'audition de jacques
pélissard le président de l'association
des maires de france était auditionné
mardi
ici au sénat par la mission commune
d'information sur les rythmes scolaires
il a bien sûr plaider la cause des
maires sur cette réforme vous le savez
controversée tout en se déclarant
satisfait par les annonces budgétaires
faites par le ministre de l'éducation
vincent peillon on se retrouve tout de
suite après voilà nous allons continuer
nos notre cycle d'auditions de cet après
midi nous recevons monsieur jacques
pélissard merci cher jacques d'être avec
nous cet après-midi ce pélissard et
député de la première circonscription du
jura depuis mars 1993 jusqu'à ce jour il
est également maire de président de
l'association des maires de france
depuis 2004
et c'est à ce titre là que nous le
recevons ce jour dans le cadre de ces
auditions autour des rythmes scolaires
mais c'est le président lors du dernier
congrès donc qui datent de la semaine
dernière nous avons avec madame le
rapporteur et d'autres membres de la
commission que la mission commune
d'information nous sommes 33 membres
nous avons assisté la semaine dernière
jeudi matin au colloque qui était
consacrée tout particulièrement aux
rythmes scolaires et une présentation
très exhaustive nous a été faite de l'
enquête sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires qui a été mise en oeuvre par
l'association des maires de france
la présentation tout le monde na na pas
eu l'occasion de d'être présent jeudi
matin
donc monsieur le président je vous donne
la parole pour que vous puissiez nous
donner un petit peu le positionnement de
l'association des maires de france et au
vu de l'éclairage de cette de cette
enquête
merci
merci merci ma présidente mme allard
auteure chaque oeil et de votre audition
sur un sujet qui a toujours préoccupé
depuis longtemps l'association air
france puisque avant même le congrès de
novembre 2012 qui n'a permis d'écrire
présent publique monsieur hollande nous
avions attiré l'attention du
gouvernement du premier ministre et du
président sur les sujets financiers
il nous fallait effectivement une aide
de l'état pour engager cette action est
sûre je suis être calendrier et
souvenez-vous pour ceux qui étaient
présents au congrès novembre 2012
présente un joli françois hollande
c'est un gage effectivement sur le fond
d'amorçage pour 2013 qui n'avait pas été
évoquée avant le congrès c'était donc
une première innovation et deuxième
nation sur la possibilité de choisir
pour les mères entre mise en place en
septembre 2013 ou en une mise en place
en septembre 2014 donc ça a été des
avancées donc mais très tôt
l'association des maires de france
cette vraiment mobilisés sur ce sujet
qui était pas évident en main en
effectuant des amodiations au projet
initial de monsieur peillon ça c'est ce
qui s'est passé donc congrès de novembre
et puis on a continué notre travail de
chiffrage en particulier du goûte de
leurs d'activités périscolaires est
arrivé un chiffre médian qui était à
l'idée de 150 euros
certaines communes sont en dessous mais
beaucoup sont au dessus donc c'est pas
une moyenne c'est un chiffre médian de
150 euros qui est à mon sens un chiffre
bas si on multiplie les 150 euros par et
six millions d'enfants qui sont
scolarisés dans notre pays on atteint la
somme de 900 millions d'euros ce qui est
une fois par an ce qui est une somme
assez considérable nous avons donc
ensuite continué sur le début d'année
2013 et c'était l'apogée au congrès des
maires de france dans une prez nos
pourparlers avec le gouvernement sur
plusieurs sujets premier jet sa question
donc du fond de compensation
la prolongation de l'amorçage juillet et
moi j'ai été reçu par
par monsieur ayrault on était de 9
octobre 2013 et s'est engagée de façon
constructive dans le dire et j'ai dit
d'ailleurs publiquement à ce que les
soutiens aux collectivités soient
maintenus en 2014 par rapport à celle
qui a déjà engagé en 2013 au départ
fonds d'amorçage n'était prévu pour que
pour 2013 donc sans reprendre le mot
fonds d'amorçage il affirmé le principe
du maintien des aides de l'état de la
cnaf au profit des collectivités qui
s'engageront en 2014
c'est souvenez-vous 50 l'euro de mémoire
de base paraît élèves inscrits dans
l'école plus 40 en fonction des zones
urbaines sensibles des zones de
revitalisation rurale plus de moi 54
euros la cnaf
donc tout ça c'est ce qui était actée
par monsieur ayrault pour 2014
donc ensuite se pose à preuve la
question évidente de la pérennisation de
dépenses et des ressources au-delà 2014
pour 2015 est né qui suivait sur ce
registre moi j'ai posé la question
monsieur héros lorsqu'il est venu devant
le congrès demain france en enlevant en
2013 donc quelques quelques jours et ne
s'est pas encore engagé aimerait qu'il y
ait une évaluation met donc on a une
première demande financière sur la
planète et pérennisation de ce fonds qui
étaient importantes pour nous qui va
neutre pour l'état puisque c'est donc
une somme de québec et même de 370
millions d'euros
donc on n'est pas loin de 400 millions
qui étaient notre notre chiffre
elle nous donne aux calculs dont 300
sont 10 millions d'euros par an
c'est considérable et s'impose est la
question que j'ai énoncé sur l'intérêt
ce type d'action réforme des rythmes
scolaires
un temps en activité de risque vers
impacte donc de cette mesure
un pack de son son effet positif par
rapport à son coûte
j'ai au passage dit qu'il était
important que lyon 1 d'une concertation
une négociation avec l'état quel que
soit le gouvernement pour en amont
évaluez négocier voir dans quel contexte
les mesures publiques décidées par
l'état qui s'impose aux collectivités
ont un impact financier acceptable pour
tous et un intérêt justifiant le coût de
la mesure
voilà donc la porte - partie financière
que justin abordé deuxième partie nous
avons demandé aussi de la souplesse
d'abord sur les normes d'encadrement là
aussi le présent public nous n'avions
dit j'avais dit quartier venus nous voir
en en septembre 2012 qu'ils veulent
absolument injecter de la souplesse dans
la question des normes d'encadrement des
enfants pendant les heures périscolaire
et il avait répondu positivement et vous
dire été applaudi par tous les maires de
france et le décret du 2 août 2013
décline précisément cet assouplissement
des taux d'encadrement on passerait de 1
animateur pour pour 10 enfants de moins
de 6 ans un bourg 14 et de 1 pour 14 1
pour 10 8 pour les plus de 6 ans donc
aménagements allègement raisonnable et
responsable
donc tout est bien qui finit bien si on
considère le décret du 2 août 2013
mais par contre ce même gouvernement qui
ait commis un décret positif je vous le
dis le 2 août signe dans le même temps
ou presque
une convention d'objectifs et de gestion
avec la caisse nationale d'allocations
familiales qui elle-même décline par
votre circulaire le maintien des taux
d'encadrement les plus forts qu'ils
soient pour les heures périscolaire sauf
les trois heures payons donc si je
résume ça c'est un peu caricatural mais
le permettez moi de faire pour les mêmes
enfants dans les mêmes locaux avec les
mêmes activités avec les mêmes
animateurs on aurait des taux
d'encadrement différents en fonction des
heures
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas raisonnable
donc nous demandons effectivement et des
discussions sont en cours actuellement
puisque pour ministre a mis en place un
groupe de travail commun entre l'état la
mistelle dg sport
l e famille la cnaf et l'association de
la france pour trouver les possibilités
de respecter le décret du 2 août 2013 et
donc d'alléger les taux d'encadrement
donc c'est une souplesse qui est
importante en termes de coûts puisque si
nous arrivons à alléger toutes les
heures périscolaire non pas seulement
les trois heures peillon mais l'ensemble
des heures on a sorti une édition
allégée qui permettra de rentrer
j'espère ans ou presque dans la
fourchette des 100 à 150 euros que nous
devions chiffrées deuxième donc demande
plus de souplesse
puis troisième demande souplesse non pas
sur les autres nommés souplesse sur les
modalités de mise en place de la réforme
des temps d'activités périscolaires sur
deux registres première jc celui des
maternelles on s'est aperçu que j'avais
dit quand je rentrais monsieur ayrault
le 9 octobre s'aperçut que pour les
maternelles et en particulier très
petite section maternelle fait d'avoir
une approche différente
la pédagogie pour les maternelles c'est
déjà de l'éveil donc faire de l'éveil
culturel sportif c'est quasiment
surabondant par rapport à la mother bien
ici other pédagogique elle même donc je
récurer les heures sur l'étang nak cité
bascula des maternelles et faire mon
sens faire un effort réel puis 2e
souplesse que nous demandons si au
niveau du calendrier c'est vrai que
certains daz n est directeur a calé
académique des services dégâts chez un
cheval
j'ai vu lors qu'on question même nom
propre département demandé des réponses
pour le 15 octobre
ensuite des réponses pour début novembre
dans d'autres départements
encore récemment dans mon for
département ils m'ont une réponse pour
le 20 décembre alors que le premier nice
s'est engagé devant le congrès des
maires de france pour janvier pour fin
janvier
donc il ya un peu d'ordre à m dans la
souplesse que le gouvernement a accordé
et que les bazennes décline pas sachant
que ensuite il faudra non seulement
s'engager sur le type de semaine que
l'on souhaite des trois heures est ce
que ces trois fois trois quarts d'heure
est ce que ces sujets quatre fois en
quarts d'heure
ce que deux fois une heure et demie est
ce que ces trois fois une heure dans
tout ça souhaite qu'elles aient le choix
entre le mercredi matin est celui
atteint sur calais puis ensuite il ya
d'autres échéances
ils sont l'objet de négociations après
les municipales et jusqu'à l'été 2014
pour la mise en place d et ambac cité
pas risqué à feu même voilà ce que je
dois dire que son nom pas luminaires
mais en prenant et pour moitié le mot
deuxième moitié au bout c'est que
l'association des maires de france
c'était son rôle elle assumer en tout
esprit de responsabilité et de respect
des opinions des uns et des autres à se
souhaiter a envoyé un questionnaire aux
4000 commune sur 24 milles qui dispose
d'une école donc on envoyait 6 ie de
questionnaires jeudi au passage au
passage je suis un peu sur sur le
contrat gorge plutôt en passant par le
relais de nos associations
départementales
le ministère n'a pas voulu n'a pas voulu
nous donner la liste des communes qui
est dépassé assène ou quatre jours et
demi donc avec compass parler les
asociaux départementale pour identifier
les communes et il a renvoyé le
questionnaire
bref on envoyait le questionnaire on est
un retour sur ferhi be1 et que tu es qui
suit le dossier de façon très très
précise au tour précisant un retour
extrêmement important par rapport aux
enquêtes de ce type et genre sur
plusieurs choses d'abord que les
communes qui sont passés aux quatre
jours et demi par volontariat de leur
part dès septembre 2013 sont satisfaites
à 83%
alors c'est un billet à la fois
quantitatifs et qualitatifs et
quantitatifs bien quantitatif c'est une
minorité de communes ces 4000 sur 24
milles donc il faut bien prendre les
choses avec les précautions bien biais
non seulement quantitatif mais aussi
qualitatif
ce sont les communes qui étaient
volontaires qui ont souhaité passer au
sun capture et demi dès septembre
donc on peut alors demander aujourd'hui
ce que vous avez fait une bêtise ou pas
il ya un lien biais que je dois en tout
ont été menées de thé intellectuelle
signé première chose deuxième chose sur
ce questionnaire et il ya une
satisfaction jeudi 83% et même 17 % de
mécontents d'insatisfaits qui regarde
passer de passer ses minoritaires mais
c'est trois fois plus que le sondage de
monsieur peillon du même en passant par
le relève et la zenn qui époque seul
apparaître un taux de 2 nde satisfaction
de 5%
donc là on mettait à 17 deuxième chose
puis troisième chose c'est là que ça
rejoint mon mon premier point que
j'abordais devant vous mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs ces questions
financières 77%
c'est énorme 77% des communes qui ont
voulu que des pionnières qui sont passés
donc dès septembre 2013
à seulement 80 me 77% donc estime et
relate qu'elles ont eu des difficultés
financières pour faire face au coût de
la réforme il encore ce n'est qu'une
projection on a fait son âge quelques
semaines après seulement après la mise
en oeuvre ce dispositif
donc ça peut s'améliorer nous ça peut
s'aggraver
ça je peux pas le dire mais 77% ça c'est
un livre qui apparaît dans le document
que mme la présidente a souhaité alors
moi ce que je demande aujourd'hui ce que
nous demandons c'est effectivement que
ya deux shows autre chose un accord sur
la pérennisation du du soutien êtes dans
une période où où les croissances la
croissance des recettes fiscales est une
réalité dans une période où les
dotations d'état augmentait avec leur
indexation sur l'inflation
on aurait pu supporter mais là on subit
par ailleurs un effet ciseau dont la mef
a dénoncé la réalité jouent toutes ces
structures d'où ces clivages politiques
puisque le président du cfl et qui n'est
pas d'eux mêmes sans suite et moi eu le
même discours que moi des charges qui
augmentent des dotations qui baisse
au passage cette charge nouvelle 900
millions d'euros au bas mot ça aggrave
effectivement largement l'effet ciseau
donc il faut absolument que l'état
pérennise au delà de 2014
le soutien aux collectivités pour les
autres activités mensuelles le moment au
deuxième chose j'ai déjà évoqué une 6-2
pas l'allègement des des taux
d'encadrement telle que prévue par le
décret du 2 août 2013 qu'il faut
appliquer vos billets même si l'état
dans à force de tutelle qui l'exercent
tort un peu le coup à la liste nationale
a vu le poignet de gros coups
les templeuvois n'y ait acquis
essentiellement la question puis 3 une
chose modalités de souplesse le pot au
lait maternel
et puis pour le le délai de mise en
oeuvre avec une écoute et communes mois
jugent qu'ils ont vu sur ce point chaque
oeil la même position
souvenez vous à l'époque pour le service
minimum d'accueil j'ai dit il faut
absolument injecter la souplesse et
l'époque de souplesse avait injecté
puisque en effet la distinction au
niveau de l'état entre les communes qui
ne voulait pas et communes qui ne
pouvaient pas hélas avec une qui ne
peuvent pas c'est vrai que beaucoup
rencontrent des problèmes d'animateur en
général mais par seulement en zone
urbaine aussi sa part dans l'étude il
faut trouver des animateurs
il faut les motiver pour venir des
finances et pour qu'il y ait dans une
eau minérale et puis il faut aussi
j'allais question de locaux parfois il
ya des dans le tiers des cas des
questions de locaux ou les instituteurs
ne veulent pas qu'on serve de la classe
qui pourtant une propriété commune pour
un autre usage que pédagogique elle fait
enfin un peu de souplesse pour faire
face à l'ensemble des difficultés que je
viens ma président amar porter et le
médiateur de pour la tête en vous merci
beaucoup monsieur le président avec
madame la rapporteure nous avons pris
l'initiative de vous solliciter pour que
nous puissions être destinataire de des
plaques être relative aux sondages pour
que nous puissions nous vous les
transmettre chers collègues pour ceux
qui n'ont pas pu se rendre jeudi matin
au colloque au congrès dé muller merci
monsieur le président je vais
immédiatement transmettre la la parole
donné la parole à madame l'art
porteur pour les questions qu'elle
souhaite proposer merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président
j'aurais à la fois quelques questions
complémentaires et peut-être aussi vous
demander un sentiment alors une question
complémentaire par rapport aux sondages
que vous avez fait est ce que vous avez
fait une distinction entre communes
rurales et communes urbaines
est ce que dans vos réponses really à
davantage de communes rurales que deux
communes urbaines qui sont passés ou
inversement
et est ce qu'il y a des difficultés qui
apparaissent plus du domaine des
territoires ruraux que des territoires
urbains
ça c'est la première question la
deuxième c'est vrai que lorsque il ya eu
les tables rondes
au congrès jeudi il y avait alors parmi
les questions posées il ya la
problématique pour un certain nombre de
communes de trouver le personnel adéquat
et donc un élu avait témoigné dans le
cadre d'une mutualisation de
l'inexpérience de groupements
d'employeurs est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus et est ce que cela peut
être une réponse justement à ces
difficultés pour les communes
et puis il y à aussi
donc vous avez parlé de
l'assouplissement des taux d'encadrement
alors c'est vrai que dans le décret du
ministre est je crois sans doute sous la
pression de la cnaf
c'était une expérimentation pour trois
ans et alors moi je ne sais pas où vous
en êtes des contacts et des dialogues
qu'on pouvait avoir avec la cnaf parce
que sur le terrain les maires sont un
peu confrontés une espèce de
culpabilisation par rapport la caf local
nous explique non mais augmenter les
taux d'encadrement cbc la qualité c'est
et je crois que ce discours là il est
préjudiciable parce que
les maires se trouve un petit peu pris
en étau parce que ils ne veulent pas ils
n'ont pas conscience qu'ils vont
abaisser la qualité mais comment leurs
portes un peu ce discours ce discours
peut être aussi relayé après par
d'autres et moi je ne sais pas si vous
allez avoir justement des des contacts
avec la cnaf mais peut-être que on vous
demanderais d'être le porte-parole de
tous ces maires pour qu' on ne nous
tiennent plus ce genre de ce genre de
discours de discours monsieur le
président merci mon à présent mais un
porteur merci pour vos questions
questionne géré pendant en duo avec
monsieur jribi qui a suivi enquête qui a
contribué à son dépouillement
alors ma question je famille qu'il
ferait donc pas le specis des poèmes
éducation au sein du département
affaires sociales culturelles et
scolaires l'association des maires de
france agence commune rurale commune
urbaine c'est vrai qu'il ya eu la prise
en compte des différences mais monsieur
hery be
oui alors effectivement sur les 1100
réponse que la nef a reçu donc de la
part des communes volontaires pour
l'application de cette réforme il y a un
peu plus de 700 communes de moins de
2000 habitants donc vu effectivement la
proportion de villages et de communes
rurales en france bien entendu la
majorité des communes qui a souhaité
appliquer cette réforme ce sont des
petites communes les communes de moins
de 2000 habitants
s'agissant des difficultés effectivement
dans les réponses libre puisqu'il y
avait une possibilité pour les mères de
s'exprimer il reçoit un besoin enfin
hausse
on sent un certain sentiment d'isolement
de la part d'un certain nombre de maires
ruraux qui n'ont pas été toujours épaulé
par les services de l'éducation
nationale ou par jeunesse et sports
également donc ça effectivement c'est
ressorti donc un souhait d'être mieux
accompagnée en milieu rural pour autant
d'après les résultats de notre enquête
c'est vrai que il ya un certain nombre
de difficultés pour recruter des
animateurs ou des problèmes de locaux et
ça c'est un problème en milieu rural
mais c'est un vrai problème en milieu
urbain donc ça ça a été un peu
techniquement nous on pensait que ce
problème là seraient plus importants
liot rural donc on était un petit peu
surpris mais il ya tout de même de vrais
problèmes en milieu rural mais un
problème encore plus important en milieu
urbain semble-t-il
compte tenu de l'effet volume bien
entendu je tente une explication
personnelle même pas validé pense qu'au
milieu urbain il ya une demande
qualitatif plus forte qui peut expliquer
la difficulté de trouver des animateurs
spécialisés encore milieu rural est une
approche vengeance - - gueye via tissus
en termes de types d'activités vos hôtes
aux enfants alors deuxième question à
l'inventeur raison la mutualisation
entre employeurs est une bonne formule
réparé avec le promoteur de se dissoudre
dans la région dans votre région
donc mon sud ouest gironde cmj darbion
qui est mis en place ce dispositif ce
peut être une solution mais ça prend un
peu de temps tous à sa peau un peu de
temps à peine actuelle et par forcément
très facile pour arriver à bien générer
cette utilisation
entre employeurs qui vont être en
situation de réflexion non sans quelques
quelques mois
puis troisième question l'inventeur sur
le le décret du 2 août
c'est vrai qu'il prévoit une application
pour alléger harmonisées pour les tempes
ayant su finir avec un des trois ans
mais nous on est d'accord sur trois ans
on fera le point dans trois ans pour
refaire le point un bon intermédiaire
d'étape dans un an demi en quelques mois
il faut enclencher dispositif
on verra si c'est jouable ou pas moi ça
me paraît raisonnable par rapport au
temps pédagogique même où l'encadrement
est moins fort on pourra effectuer avoir
une région raisonnable on baisse de 4,6
à pas dramatique mais ça va mal assortis
d'alléger le coude pour les communes qui
effectivement bien besoin
nous irons sur ces deux questions
oui aux délais évaluation intermédiaire
pourquoi pas mais avec la prise en
compte d'un allègement qui est justifiée
dans d'autres domaines et de belgique en
particulier mais déjà bénéficier de cet
allégement puisqu'elle qu'un enseignant
pour les primaires pour les castes de 25
ou 30
merci monsieur le président nous allons
prendre une succession de plusieurs
questions
si vous permettez chers collègues en est
une je la poserai immédiatement monsieur
le président est-ce qu'il n'était pas un
petit peu hâtif et précipité d'annoncé
vous l'avez dit c'est un chiffre médian
mais le coot de fixer l'association des
maires de france à 150 euros
cela a généré de nombreuses crispation
lorsque certaines communes qui se sont
engagés dans cette réforme se sont
rendus compte que finalement il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de kout
complémentaires qui s'ajoutaient
finalement au coût de même de la dédier
à la réforme notamment les transports et
que pour certaines communes on arrive à
plus de 500 euros par part enfants par
an ce qui a amené le évidemment le
gouvernement à ceux à proposer ces 50
euros mais qui ne sont plus du tout si
vous voulez en adéquation avec le coot
réel aujourd'hui ceux constatés sur
certaines communes
est ce que est ce que votre votre
précipitation n'a pas un petit peu
crispée tout la situation
dans ce contexte la ccl un petit peu
c'est pas du tout une fronde monsieur le
président mais c'est un questionnement
la seconde question sera posée par
monsieur fauconnier se payant d'abord je
voulais vous remercier et vous féliciter
pour la tenir ce congrès que nous
annoncer un congrès à haut risque dans
le contexte actuel et je pense que très
sincèrement ou n'y était pas pour rien
si tout ça s'est très bien passé donc je
voulais vous remercier très sincèrement
de questions une question sur joe
revient sur les problèmes de de normes
de la cnaf on a beaucoup d'entre nous
ont des contrats locaux ont des contrats
enfin son décès l'excès des terrains
si vous pouviez dans les rencontres vous
auriez à l'avenir demandé qu'on mette un
peu de l'ordre dans tout ça de façon à
ce qu'il y ait une cohérence un but je
sais que c'est une demande de
l'association mais maintenant il ya
urgence personne est en train de
renégocier tous ses contrats ya de
fortes craintes pour les mères en
particulier qu'à cette occasion là on
déplace à des financements en
bidouillant un petit peu les choses et
je crois que ça serait préjudiciable
pour nos collectivités ainsi vous pouvez
en terrine saison ça me semblait plus
tout ça je me semble être une bonne
chose deuxième question sur les
financements
on entend ici ou là mais je sais que ça
ils en ont quelques fois discuté dans
des associations de demers au niveau des
départements sur la façon de comptes de
de dison de financer la réforme est ce
que ce serait pas judicieux plus
judicieux en particulier pour les
petites communes de faire deux systèmes
un système qui serait un système qui
lisserait le seuil d'effectif c'est à
dire un système de dotation par site et
un système par élève
parce que le système par élève sur les
petites communes où les petites classes
c'est le système ils sont très
pénalisant pas ce que vous avez
douze élèves ça existe il ya beaucoup
aujourd'hui l'école encore qui ont dix
quinze élèves à 90 euros par élève venir
laissent vite fait le tour du la
situation dans l'idée d'avoir deux mais
thor un site en mettant les 1500 euros
l'un sait rien pour le site et puis
après une décote plus forte par élève
ça me semblerait plus juste les choses
sont bien sûr différentes dans les
établissements dans les grandes villes
voilà tout ça pour dire quand même j'ai
fait partie de ceux qui ont répondu à
votre demande puisque j'ai mis en place
les rythmes scolaires et portal et
l'inquiétude c'est vrai mais d'une façon
générale ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que les parents les enfants sont très
très très heureux voilà merci cher
collègue monsieur cadran oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur monsieur
le président c'est vrai que je n'ai pas
fait le même choix que mon collègue faux
collier de la mise en place dès 2013
mais je peux constater je peux confirmer
aussi les ses propos c'est à dire que à
travers la réflexion que l'on a mis que
l'on a mises en place avec des parents
les enseignants et par site de proximité
puisque j'ai une commune de gémir une
commune de 14 mille habitants emile 1400
élèves sur six écoles
cette discussion se fait école par école
parents enseignants et personnels
communaux
donc ça aussi c'est très important dans
la négociation dans les discussions je
confirme que personne ne remet en cause
le motif de la réforme et je crois que
dans l' enquête que vous avez fait il
n'y a pas de remise en cause de du
principe de la réforme
ce qui pose question est ce qui nous
interroge effectivement et j'ai bien
entendu que il y avait une sorte de
sentiment d'isolement de la part d'un
certain nombre d'élus alors quelles
seraient les préconisations en face que
fait que fait la mf en matière
d'accompagnement également vous l'avez
vous l'avez souligné
et puis quand on parle de coups madame
la présidente
d'interpeller tout à l'heure sous le
chiffre de 100 150 euros tout dépend ce
que l'on met dans l'est dans le coup ce
que l'on considère comme étant le coup
moi j'étais en train de regarder pour ma
collectivité 150 euros je pense qu'on
est bien d'accord c'est la somme médiane
hors restauration scolaire qu'on
pourrait proposer aux enfants le
mercredi
donc effectivement 150 euros moi j'ai
fait le calcul j'arrive à 140 euros dont
vous voyez
mais par contre si j'ajoute la
restauration scolaire le mercredi midi
pour les enfants qui vont en centre de
loisirs par exemple là et ça peut créer
un appel d'air pour les enfants ce qui
est très bien pour nos centres de
loisirs ça peut être générateur
d'emplois aussi mais ça peut avoir un
coût un coût supérieur parce que
effectivement on perd quelque part la
collectivité assume quelque part une
somme supplémentaire sur sur sur les
repas et pour rejoindre la réflexion de
de monsieur fauconnier il y a en milieu
rural beaucoup de communes qui ont ce
qu'on appelle des rapprochements
pédagogique avec effectivement des
effectifs léger avec une notion de coût
de transport est ce que tu aurais pas
une réflexion à avoir
au niveau des intercommunalités alors
sans parler bien évidemment de transfert
de compétences ou autre mais avoir une
réflexion pour notamment le recrutement
par exemple des encadrants des
animateurs et cela en ayant en ayant
toujours en tête le rôle de la caf t4
locales qui selon les départements
agissent différemment
ce qui pose un souci et avec quelques
fois le sentiment que les élus sont un
peu les subordonnés de des caf quoi
alors contrairement à eux
je rappellerai que nous nous sommes élus
et qui on n'a pas tout à fait le même
patron entre guillemets voilà merci
beaucoup
madame gillot s'il vous plaît j'ai une
question cette fois-ci
monsieur le président vous évoqué à
plusieurs reprises votre engagement à
obtenir la baisse des taux d'encadrement
des activités périscolaires de toutes
les activités périscolaires
mais avez-vous évalué les conséquences
en matière de conduite de ses activités
périscolaires justement qui sont plus
souples plus détendu moins stricts en
terme de deux disciplines pour les
enfants sont en activité ils sont pas
assis à une table à écouter et à un
apprentissage donc là il ya quand même
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faudrait
apprécié et ne craignez vous pas les
conséquences en termes de responsabilité
de la conduite de c2c de ses activités
périscolaires et en termes
d'attractivité du métier d'animateur qui
peuvent craindre qu'il s'agirait d'un
recul sur les conditions d'exercice
qu'ils avaient obtenus au fil des années
et de reconnaissance de leur pratique
professionnelle
merci beaucoup
et enfin la dernière question madame
sophie primas merci madame la présidente
monsieur le président merci pour votre
exposé moi je voudrais savoir c'est au
sein de l'aef vous avez travaillé sur un
second sujet qui tient à coeur au
ministre de l'éducation mais qui tient
aussi au coeur des maires de ce pays qui
est l'école numérique car un certain
entrain nombre d'entre nous l'école
numérique parce qu'un certain nombre
d'entre nous avaient commencé à
travailler sur l'école numérique qui
représente un investissement extrêmement
important et volontariste de la part des
municipalités
cette école numérique présente également
des avantages qu'ils peuvent répondre
aux inconvénients des anciens rythmes
scolaires sur lequel nous nous accordons
tous
or aujourd'hui devant les contraintes
budgétaires nous ne pourrons pas avoir
fromage dessert nous allons devoir
regardez les rythmes scolaires et faire
attendre le numérique et c'est bien
dommage parce que nous ne pourrons pas
faire les deux par le fameux effet de
ciseaux que vous prononcez donc je me
demande s'il n'y a pas là dans la
souplesse et dans la flexibilité moi je
suis très favorable au numérique à
l'école numérique nous avons des
exemples en particulier un exemple
pionnier dans les yvelines dans la marie
d'elancourt qui est vraiment quelque
chose d'assez extraordinaire en terme de
résultats et en termes d'attention des
enfants je peux vous dire je suis encore
aller la semaine dernière voir les
enfants à 15h45 de l'après-midi sages
comme des images en visioconférence en
train de répondre en anglais
un prof qui est basée en angleterre
c'est quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire à voir bon donc il y à là
probablement peut-être quelques une
combinatoire des deux systèmes affaires
qu'il faudrait envisager d'un point de
vue également financier ce qu'encore une
fois on ne pourra pas faire fromage et
dessert bien mes chers collègues merci
de vos questions pour tous sur président
merci ma présidente
alors tout d'abord chaque question mais
des financements mais question vous est
posée que monsieur sainté n'est que
d'armand également posé gouttes du
financement en est évidemment sur un
prix moyen de 150 euros
mais 150 euros c'était hors restauration
scolaire hors transports aux locaux hors
chauffage à c'est la prestation civière
d'animation en or de toute autre coûte
c'est peut-être un chiffre inférieur
monsieur je vais vous donner de chiffres
précis qu'on a eu on monte jusqu'à 305
250 300 euros alors en fait il ne s'agit
pas c'est bien un montant médian ce
n'est pas une moyenne
en fait on a effectivement une commune
sur deux ayant répondu qu'ils chiffrent
donc le coût inférieur ou égal à 150
euros et une commune sur deux au dessus
de donc de ce montant cette répartition
vaut notamment pour les communes rurales
puisqu'elle représente
70% dans des communes ayant ayant
répondu donc on voit bien que pour 56 %
des communes de deux à dix mille
habitants
le coût est inférieur à 150 euros mais
pour les communes urbaines ces 56 %
au-dessus de 50 euros et on voit bien au
total que pour six communes sur 10 en
fait ce coût se situe entre 100 et 200
euros mais pour 25% de ces communes le
ca s'élève à plus de 200 euros donc il
ne s'agit pas d'une moyenne mais il yad
un niveau médian maître monsieur le
président c'est vrai que vous avez
clairement énoncé le faite vous avez pas
pris en considération notamment les
transports d'ailleurs nous allons
entendre l'association les départements
de france parce qu'il semblerait donc
que dans certains départements les
conseils généraux se sont désengagés sur
la prise en charge sur le mercredi matin
des transports scolaires pour les
primaires donc ça c'est un coup
supplémentaire qui va grever de façon
fondamentale les budgets des petites
communes notamment sur la question posée
par ces internats et rond je vous
connais je connais corps pour qu'on
harmonise les dispositifs c'est vrai que
il faut harmoniser il faut arrêter de
d'empiler les systèmes qui sont goûteux
ils sont pas forcément cohérent les uns
avec les autres
moi je les dis à mon propre la zenn leaf
absolument que les heures pédagogique
soit des heures assumée par l'éducation
nationale
qu'on cesse d'intervenir pendant le
temps pédagogique ce quelqu'un on
intervient actuellement nous pendant
tant de la grille dans ma ville et qu'on
bascule tout ce qui est donc heures
d'activités périscolaires en dehors du
temps pédagogique donc rock / / juste là
il faut qu'on ait cette harmonisation
des dispositifs peut-être monsieur ferry
by peut compléter mon propos sur les
normes d'encadrement il ne s'agit pas
d'une obligation c'est une ouverture
possible pour les communes
on voit bien d'après l'anc est que
d'après les communes ayant répondu six
communes sur 10 appliquerait ces normes
alléger donc ça semble répondre à un
besoin d'un certain de communes
maintenant un certain nombre de communes
ne soit pas appliquée c'est au alléger
sa effectivement nous le savons mais il
s'agit d'une ouverture donc la commune a
le choix de mettre en place ou pas les
activités sur la base de ses taux à
l'egypte ou non en tout cas c'est vrai
que ces communes ont la possibilité de
mettre en place des activités et c'est
pour aider notamment les petites
communes rurales à mettre en place des
activités éducatives organisées c'est
bien de ça le but initial voilà ce que
sur le financement de la réforme
l'idée que vous soumettez vos collègues
ici assemblée un système pas un élève
complété par un système par site paraît
une idée à creuser
je suis ouvert à ça james british
différents pour eux et 50 et 40 euros
donc 3 10 euros par élève inscrit et
puis l'est de la cnaf par élèves
présents donc on peut effectivement
avoir une approche différenciée en
fonction de la taille des communes alors
sur monsieur s'interdit côtes d'armor
oui progrès chaque école par école doit
être ouverte
systech et il faut l'en sont ensuite une
harmonie sur un bassin de vie parce que
sinon ça sent plus nous aller vite
commune on n'est pas trop pénalisé mais
le conseil général qui assume et
transports scolaires sur l'institution
infernale pour mam la sénatrice jeunes
animateurs et surtout d'encadrement moi
je pense qu'il faut laisser aux mères le
soin de se décider de son taux
d'encadrement mais il faut qu' il y ait
au moins la possibilité d'utiliser les
taux à alléger il ya des communes où il
paye art parfaitement un toit léger
harmonisée sur l'ensemble du temps
d'activités périscolaires des communes
où il faut peut-être plus de soutien
plus de présence d'animateurs les
publics sont différents on sent tout ce
qu'on a sont à cheval
chaque année moi je fais depuis quelques
années on va dans une classe qui désigne
son député junior on s'aperçoit que
c'est pas le même les ambiances en
fonction des classes et classes rurales
qui sont très très calme dans le
quartier des quartiers calmes puis en a
qui sont moins donc on peu efficient
ajustée mais les sommaires je suis
injuste et et puis dernière question mam
centris prime un moment c'est une bonne
idée
moi j'ai vu au téléphone jean michel
fourgous qui m'a expliqué ce qu'il
faisait en matière d'école numérique
fois que c'est à mon sens une dimension
possible dans le cadre des activités
périscolaires
mais c'est un choix du maire avec l'aval
donc du dden dans le cadre du projet du
gaz il territoriales qui ait une
dimension numérique moi ça me percement
ça ne me choque pas ça peut être donc un
apprentissage numérique
pourquoi pas de langue voudrait bien
voir un visage un peu ludique de langue
pas forcément l'apprentissage donc dur
comme un peu de vie dans notre enfance
passage ludique des langues avec des
lecteurs étrangers
ça peut être en france une ouverture et
son numérique et langue parfaitement
compatible avec le dispositif se pose la
question du coup tu pourrais question du
coup tu es là aussi il faut qu'on ait au
moins les 470 millions et 400 millions
d'euros et 70 millions 1 à figer bas
monsieur ayrault pour nous à nous
permettent de faire face pour partie
pour partie dernière chose que je suis
aux anges planète suspense jusqu'au bout
il ya certaines communes c'est le cas la
mienne par exemple nous avions déjà des
activités presque qui existait donc on
va les recycler si je puis dire dans le
cadre des heures payant donc c'est pas
un surcoût de ce moment là et ça rentre
dans l'estimation des 150 euros de
surcoût par rapport à ce qui existait ça
vient aussi en en diminution du montant
global de l'addition
je suivais riboud je voulais juste
ajouter donc sur les normes fectivement
léger un certain nombre de communes nous
ont fait comprendre que elle souhaitait
appliquer des taux allégées mais pas
forcément pour tout les activités
puisque ça c'est vraiment important
c'est en fonction des activités et
jusqu'à présent des communes ne
comprenais pas pourquoi il fallait
appliquer des taux si aussi aussi
important pour toutes les activités donc
cette souplesse va permettre à certaines
communes de pouvoir mieux organiser
leurs activités par rapport à la cnaf
effectivement la demande de la nfc
effectivement de permettre un allègement
des normes sur l'ensemble des heures
périscolaire des dès le mois de janvier
et qu'il y ait ensuite une évaluation
effectivement de notamment pour le
budget de la cnaf la cnaf qui donc là
nous sommes en pleine négociation avec
le conseiller du premier ministre et les
ministères de l'éducation nationale
jeunesse et sports et la cnaf
navx qui est plutôt aujourd'hui en
retrait dans la mesure où elles estiment
qu'ils auraient un risque à ce que
certaines communes finalement qui ont
aujourd'hui un système de surveillance
puissent passer à un système de centre
de loisirs donc avec des activités
encadrées puisque certaines communes ont
déjà des taux d'encadrement assez
similaires à des taux d'encadrement
aller j'ai donc assez proche et pourrait
être un site est effectivement rentré
dans ce nouveau dispositif et la cnaf
nous dit que ne pourraient pas
effectivement assumées les incidences
financières mais pour le moment il
s'agit effectivement de risque mais qui
ne sont pas du tout étayé
on a émis l'idée gérer correctement on
pourrait avoir une évaluation donc six
mois après
pas question de prendre les gens très
vite question d'évaluer combien ça coûte
comment on peut être aidé et quelle est
l'incidence d'un allégement harmonisée
des taux d'encadrement juste sur le
numérique ou pour finir équipements
plusieurs associations d'élus dont la
nef vont organiser le jeudi 5 décembre à
lyon une journée sur le numérique à
l'école en lien notamment avec donc le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
notamment sur le partenariat entre
l'état et donc les régions départements
et communes
merci beaucoup merci de ces explications
de ces éclairages on se rend compte
qu'il ya effectivement encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes qui n'ont pas de réponse
aujourd'hui qui exige des évaluations je
ne suis pas certaine que l'ensemble de
ces évaluations puisse aboutir à des
propositions supportable pour l'entrée
en vigueur de ces rythmes scolaires en
2014 en tout cas notre mission va se
s'approprier ce sujet là pour
effectivement apporter des réponses
autant que possible aux élus locaux
merci beaucoup monsieur pélissard
d'avoir que vous de nous avoir consacré
votre temps ce soir
merci malheureusement marc batta merci
chers collègues
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition de
jacques pélissard devant la mission
commune d'information sur les rythmes
scolaires
vous retrouverez dans un instant
delphine girard pour 24 heures sénat